didier maïsto président de sud radio
bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être un
rythme sur rt france tout d'abord votre
commentaire sur ce qu'a dit patrick
cohen sur l'émission c'est à vous je ne
vais pas polémiquer avec monsieur cohen
il nous a habitués à être qui jours du
côté du manche du côté de la
communication officielle
effectivement face à ce que nous
traversons aujourd'hui et toutes les
autorités l'ont dit avec beaucoup de
retard certes je crois que la polémique
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour les comptes
seront ceux nés après après cette crise
après cette vague mais c'est tout à fait
indigne et je crois que les tweets que
vous avez passé à l'antenne de thomas
porcher et où d'autres démontrent bien
que ce qu'il faut en penser quoi c'est à
dire c'est la crête des vagues l'hôpital
les services publics ont été
effectivement détruit les alertes des
nombreux praticiens du camp dicale des
aides soignants des infirmières n'ont
pas été entendus rihanna était anticipé
je rappelle mais vous l'avez vous même
qu'il n'y avait pas de masque et pas de
gel pas de respirateur on parle de
quelques milliers d'opérateurs il en
faudrait dix ou vingt fois plus un
engorgement des hôpitaux des services de
réanimation et puis d'ailleurs on peut
pas dire qu'on ne savait pas puisque dès
2016 le docteur salomon qui avait fait
quelques préconisations à la leur
candidat manuel macron avait bien
expliqué qu'en cas de crise majeure
nous n'étions pas préparés alors on se
paye de mots meilleurs services
sanitaires du monde meilleur système de
santé meilleur système social et c'est
donc aujourd'hui malheureusement on voit
bien qu'il n'ya plus d'état
véritablement c'est une petite équipe il
fait du marketing et de la
câlinothérapie
il n'y a plus d'europe explosion
implosion tu sais pas comment il faut
dire cela de l'europe qui est
complètement décalé complètement absente
et puis dépendance notamment vis à vis
de la chine mais toutes les personnes
comme un certain nombre en france qu'il
avait dit des 92 une lors de
la sphère de maastricht avait dit qu'un
pays s'était avéré qu'ils devaient
d'être souverain avec un système de
santé un système social économique et
des choix les choix qui lui
appartiennent c'est sami nations là on
s'est donné un petit peu au bras des
plus offrant pour l'ailé pour la loi du
marché et on voit bien que la
technostructure qui est très présent
parce que quand on regarde nombre de
deux étages au ministère de la santé une
institution que je connais bien les
agences régionales de santé
on peut pas dire qu'il n'y ait pas de
personnel lancer dans ces grands dans
ces grands immeubles un peu à la brasil
c'est la fin d'un système donc
aujourd'hui l'heure n'est pas à la
polémique
et moi je la cite à partir de ce jour
parce qu'on va dans une passe très
difficile
heureuse et probablement des milliers de
victimes à tous ces grands théoriciens
et redresseur de tort de faire preuve si
c'est possible sinon le silence du moins
un minimum d'humilité mais ce terme
choisi de gilet jaune isation de la
crise quand on n'est pas d'accord avec
le gouvernement on est forcément gilet
jaune ça le raccourci par air un peu un
peu court non oui c'est pile et très
dépréciatif effectivement je sais pas
s'il est court mais aujourd'hui quand
vous avez un certain nombre de faits
messager même pas d'avoir des opinions
puisque moi vous savez je me bats pour
la vérité et la vérité déchets et que
vous les corréler ou que vous les mettez
en avant
vous avez un certain nombre de personnes
qui se disent qu'ils se prétendent
autorisé à parler c'est pas nouveau
notamment dans les médias meanstream et
qui voudraient tout de suite de
complotiste de conspirationniste et le
loup au néologisme de le dire ainsi mais
c'est là j lo gilet jaune isation tout
ça comme je le disais en préambule est
un petit peu la crête des vagues ne
grandit pas ceux que ne grandit pas
leurs auteurs alors même que les gilets
jaunes qui étaient les citoyens a sans
doute les plus éclairés sont descendus
massivement dans la rue durant 15 mois
pour réclamer justement que l'état
fonctionne et ce qui est capital c'est
d'abord et avant tout le système
sanitaire qui coûtait trop cher
un pognon de dingue emmanuel macron en
tant que président de la république
l'avait dit il fallait faire de la
prévention ni prévention ni ventilation
dans tous les sens
donc toutes les acceptions du terme
c'est la faillite de l'état donc
aujourd'hui il faut rester uni vous faut
ne pas céder à la polémique
les comptes se feront que moi à partir
d'aujourd'hui sur twitter sur les
réseaux sociaux aux normes et de prise
de parole publique
je ne répondrai plus à ces jeunes ces
agitateurs qui font leur tube alors que
le pays traverse une passe difficile et
qui sont la petite pauline stériles
stupides politicienne
c'est tout à fait indigne et je suis
s'ils veulent dire comme de nombreux
français
scandalisé de lire et d'entendre ce
genre de propos dans la bouche de
personnes qui ont une parole publique et
qui ce qu'ils sont écoutés par des
milliers voire des millions de gens et
qu'ils font comme ça normal dans la
société française des partitions entre
ce serait autorisé à parler je ne savais
pas il m'avait été chapelet que monsieur
cohen était étudiée épidémiologue était
médecin et virologue
moi je le croyais et commentateurs de la
vie politique qui se cantonne à
commenter la vie politique en étant
toujours du côté où le vent souffle
c'est la seule chose qu'on lui demande
il nous a habitués à ça mais de grâce de
grâce qui ne se pique pas de faire de la
médecine qui n'attaque pas les
différents professeurs comme le
professeur out moi je ne sais pas si le
professeur out aboutira je ne suis pas
médecin on a dit qu'ils étaient
enneigées les jours
également effectivement le professeur
raoul tu as été qualifiée de docteurs
des gilet jaune également
oui mais vous vous rendez compte vous
rendez compte où nous en sommes à quel
niveau
ras des pâquerettes aujourd'hui quelle
est la situation vous voyez que la
france après l'italie traverse une passe
très difficile
vous avez été d'aider nos anciens qui
meurt tout seul dans les ehpad sans
qu'on puisse les accompagner
vous avez les animations qui sont
saturés les personnels qui sont fatigués
travaille avec des sacs poubelles et ce
qu'ils trouvent sous la main pour
essayer d'être immunisé et qui sont au
front vous avez des gens comme nous qui
continue à travailler des commerçants
des gens dans l'île dont les médias dans
des caissières qui sont toujours pour
informer vous pourra de servir les gens
dans les produits de première nécessité
et vous avez des gens comme ça
superfétatoire qui viennent commenter
les choses de la vie et kick kss kss kss
katif
qu'at-il fait pour le pays ce monsieur
pour se croire autorisé à parler donc
aujourd'hui il y a différentes
tentatives
j'espère comme de jeunes de garder la
tête froide comme de nombreux français
que la chloroquine associé à
l'antibiotique face sont des faits que
ça fonctionne nous le souhaitons tous
n'a pas à s'ériger comme ça en oms 10
qui se contente de relater les faits et
tout le monde sera content mais vous
savez depuis 15 mois que je suis dans la
rue
malheureusement je suis habitué à ce
genre de traitement
tout à fait condescendant tout à fait
odieux de la part de finalement de ce
qu'on peut appeler le système médiatico
politique qui lui-même fait du duce king
et de check-in tracts n'est ce pas et
qui nous disent ce qu'on doit penser à
penser et c'est aussi la critique à
travers tout cela évidemment de cette
formidable expression populaire à
travers les réseaux sociaux qui sont pas
là
c'est mais on va pas non plus empêcher
les gens de réfléchir d'échangés
d'espérer de cb d'avoir un esprit
critique aiguisé
c'est aussi ça le peuple français mais
aujourd'hui effectivement nous sommes
dans une forme de guerre pour preuve
certains visible c'est pas la peine de
polémiquer c'est vraiment tout à fait
impardonnable et les comptes et vous
verrez qu'ils seront faits
malheureusement je ne crois pas tout à
fait dans la sérénité parce que les gens
en ont plus que ras-le-bol de ces
censeurs merci beaucoup didier maïsto
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france j'y rajoute d'ailleurs les
routiers qui sont eux aussi en première
ligne on les oublie bien trop souvent
merci didier maïsto merci